4層を止めて早2週間くらいが経った僕はここに来れてさまざまなコンビニを回った
しかしまだ俺の心に響かコンビニはないのでファミリーマートに行ってね
コンビニっていうのはちょっと早めに攻+んですよ商品商品でこの季節
に食べたいものとかなんでもう殿堂が肉まんとかもう
バンバン建ってますね
うんん
サリーモンスターズインクのサリーのビッグマンです
ん
それまぁちょっとブサイクっ
ちょっとカッペからもう5時間くらいだったんであっためてきます
me
おっ
ん
いやーなんかローさんと違ってないかん
変な物を作りますね悪口じゃないですよ
いいみたいですよ言われだけこれサイトわかんないよなんか
子供が悪ふざけで作った方ねっ
お父さんみたいな感じですよ
かわいそうな顔ねーこのスーパー議会の俺がちょっとかっこよくしてあげよう
女は基本的に
芽取りやすいですね今ね結構ね大事なパーツなんです名がないともうダメみたいな
ところよ
me
サブ ra
うん足はしっかりしてますなんだっけこれ
醤油にくましろ肉まん
よくわかんないんですけど
父ガスものすごい物騒な色してるんですけど
中身はしっかりモンスターズインクです
ディズニーにつけそうな味ですねそのモンスターの君たちの
買ってみたらいいよじゃじゃーん
ん
入った
うん